it feels like this was the week that
Labour really picked aside pushing for a
second Brack set referendum you're
speaking to us from your constituency
Hayes which voted to leave so my
question to you is why should your
constituents who voted out at the
referendum really have the confidence to
vote in other elections if they feel
that they vote could just be ignored
remember what we're doing at the moment
we're abiding by first of all a
manifesto commitment we said we'd
respect the referendum but we also said
we wouldn't allow Theresa May to take us
out of Europe or the reckless steal and
we would not support No Deal so what
we're doing is exactly is our Party
conference unanimously decided we're
still arguing for our proposal which is
a deal we think can protect jobs in the
economy and we're still arguing if that
doesn't go through we should have a
general election but we've recognized
but actually two if we have to to block
No Deal and to block a bad deal we'll
have to go back to the people themselves
and with my constituents I think they'll
understand that because we we can't
allow a no deal or a bad deal to go
through that will affect their jobs and
undermine our economy but we've we've
been forced into this by Teresa made
delaying running down the clock and not
coming up with a compromise that we
could all support I know that you are
saying that this is the natural
progression from that confidence most
conference motion but at the same time
you are now pushing for a second
referendum you want to put down an
amendment in Parliament for MPS to
actually vote for it and yourself have
come on a bit of a journey on this
haven't you because in 2016 you said in
a speech that Labour must not push for a
second vote to do so would put us
against the majority will of the British
people and on the side of certain
corporate elites I mean the real thing
that's changed here is mp's defecting to
join the independent group isn't it that
not had any bearing on your decision at
all no no we've been straight with
people we've been forced into this
situation why Teresa may look for two
years she's delayed and delayed and
delayed and running down the clock she's
now presented us with a deal which can't
be supported because it will have such
dire
occurrences for or for my constituents
and for the jobs of the people right the
way across the country we can't support
that we certainly can't support No Deal
which could be stratasys catastrophic so
therefore we're saying what we've got a
deal that we think could protect jobs in
the economy which we saw only two weeks
ago the European Union representatives
were keen to negotiate with us on so
therefore we still be pushing for that
but we respect the view that if we can't
get that well we will have to break the
logjam by going back to the people
that's not what we want most what we're
being forced into you say that you've
been forced into it but I just wonder I
mean you're someone who looks at these
things all the time but I just wonder
what impact this will have on the next
election because if you look at the hard
facts from the last election we had of
the 45 seats in England and Wales that
Labour needs to win to get a majority 35
voted leave and 16 of Labour's 20 most
vulnerable seats also backed brexit so
by trying to keep the membership
together to keep the party together are
you throwing away the next election you
know there's something beyond electoral
calculations and it's the interest of
the country as the the people's jobs as
their livelihoods it's the long-term
future of our economy and we you know as
politicians now I think we've got to
stand up and put the interests of the
country first and actually yes you could
look what party advantage but that isn't
where we're at at the moment where we're
at is saying we may well be but we've
got but we've got to be honest with
people you know people have had enough
of politicians who say one thing and
actually do another we're what we're
saying we said we'd respect the
referendum but we also said we can't
allow a reckless brexit the way the
trees are now is bringing its forward we
can't allow No Deal because it will have
such dire consequences but it's all in
the long-term future and we've got to be
honest with people about that and I
think the electoral calculation goes out
the window now we've got to look for the
long-term interest of our country and
our people so if it's that important you
can be whipping Labour MPs when you do
put forward this amendment on a second
what happens if any shadow ministers
break that whip they can be sacked well
normally we will whip and that will be
decided in the normal way by the chief
whip and the shadow cabinet and the
party overall I'm sure I think on an
issue is this which we would see a whip
but we also you've got to respect
people's views in their constituency
interests as well and that the old
whipping arrangement will be determined
in discussion in due course but I just
say this and I think it will be for MPS
right the way across the house in all
parties now that they've got to look to
the long-term interests of the country
they've got to protect people's jobs
they've got to protect the economy
otherwise we'll never be forgiven in the
future if we vote for something which
will damage our long-term future I think
people will look back and say where were
you when we needed you so does the
entire front bench labor front bench
need to support this policy then well
there'll be a discussion in shadow
cabinet and in the normal way we'll come
to a conclusion on the exact wording of
whatever and them and was put up and
you'd expect the front bench to support
it but as I say you know we've got to
respect people's views on this they come
from different areas different
constituencies and they'll be listening
to their own constituents and you know
it's one of those issues where you've
seen already right the way across the
house that's owned all the different
political parties there are views being
expressed which are expressed honestly
and validly that we've got to respect as
well now there's a big people's vote
March on the 23rd of March we spoke to
them this week and they said that they'd
love to have you there they'd love to
give you a speaking a slot now that
you're throwing your weight behind a
second referendum you're gonna be there
out marching well I'll think about it
certainly I not want to miss a good
March but I also have to say as well I
don't want to say anything I don't to do
anything so then that disrespects the
people who strongly in my Uncas
distancing elsewhere supported leave and
I don't want to do anything that offends
them because what I'm trying to do now
and there's a thing that Gordon Brown
said a few weeks ago you know we we
should be setting up meetings and
discussions where we bring the country
back together again and that's one of
the things I've been doing in my own
area
we're bringing people together explain
exactly the situation we're in seeing
what compromises that we can all reach
because at the end of the day you know I
think I think we all will have to unite
on the basis are very very British
compromise okay well we'll look forward
to you both starting work on your speech
next week in that case and now I'm
interested to talk to you as well about
another rather that's been brewing in
labor for some time now and that's
around these allegations of
anti-semitism and the parties handling
of it so my question to you is does the
Labour Party have a problem with
anti-semitism well we clearly do yes we
clearly do look these allegations that
the Labour Party is institutionally
anti-semitic I reject completely but
clearly we do and we've accepted that
it's it might be only what the figures
that we've got I think you interviewed
berry Garden last weekend he took you
through the figures so it's nought point
1 percent of our membership seem to have
been involved in some form of
anti-semitism
it's a tiny number but it's still a
problem I do not want one anti-semite in
our party I do not want one piece of
evidence of someone being anti-semitic
we've we've got to eradicate it from our
party because our party has got to be in
the lead with others in eradicating it
from our society I mean you say that
there's clearly a problem with
anti-semitism in the labour party even
though you want to of course and put
that in context I just wonder if
everyone does agree with you on that and
because it feels to me as if some
members of the Labour Party don't accept
them as a problem with anti-semitism we
had for example labour members cheering
Chris Williamson when he said that
labour has been too apologetic about
anti-semitism and yet in the newspapers
today John Ryan's someone who left the
Labour Party has shared a letter that
was sent to her constituency office
saying stop telling lies about Jeremy
Corbyn he's a decent man you need to be
shoved right back in the ovens I mean
Jeremy Corbyn is leader does he need to
do more hair we're all we're all doing a
lot more I'm sorry John Ryan is left I
really am I think it was a mistake I
would rather
she's stayed within the party and helped
us tackle this issue where there seems
to be some disagreements or in some of
these meetings that have taken place is
where people are saying you know the the
Labour Party is institutionally
anti-semitic rants institute the racist
I reject that completely but we have got
a problem and we've accepted that and
jeremy's said time and time again there
is an issue here there's a real problem
that we've got to address and are
addressing and that's what we're doing
and I said time and time again and we've
said this we've got to be quicker we are
I think my own view I think in some
instances we've got to be more ruthless
more severe and we're doing that and
we've we've invited where there's been
criticism for the process and I've been
one of those critics strong critics
where we've we've had Christians of the
process we've invited Lord Faulkner a
former attorney general to come in and
give us advice on those processes and I
believe he's meeting next week to agree
how he proceeds without the terms of
reference and in that way we can over
some come some of the criticisms that
we're encountering at the moment but you
know we're being completely open and
transparent about this and in that way
this sunlight I think will be the way in
which we eradicate and address this
problem effectively and I'm hoping that
will be a model for other political
parties about how they address similar
problems within their own parties and a
model for the rest of society I I listen
to Rabbi John O'Connor last week when
she did a thought for the day and she
talked through about how when you've
committed an offense you recognize it
you apologize for it but of course you
make sure you address that issue you
atone for it you change your behavior
and I think collectively as the Labour
Party in that spirit that is deep within
Judaism that's the sort of process we
need to go through and I think that's
what we started out on that path and
I'll I want to be in a number of months
prior at I'm really proud that we've
become a beacon of light of how we
address this problem I was quite struck
this week I am what I thought was
actually a very good video produced by
trying to you know address some of the
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
that we sometimes see online and also in
life as well and it was effectively
trying to say that it may be that some
people on the left are perhaps more
susceptible to some of these it says
that these sort of racist traits
effectively aim to take a basic concern
about inequality and injustice in the
world and turn that into a hatred of
Jews do you think that some on the Left
have a bit of a blind spot when it does
come to racism against Jews well there's
been a there's blind spots on left and
right and the right have been very
violently anti-semitic in our community
but yes there is an issue on the left
and I I met the people who produce that
video Michael and Harry they did a
fantastic job i retweeted it with a
comment saying this was a the sort of
material that we need to be putting out
because people will learn from it you
know I was attacked I was attacked for
retweeting that that video but actually
I think it was spot-on because what it
was produced by momentum what what
they're doing in this is what's
happening the Labour Party as well is
saying look there's a lot of ignorance
about anti-semitism in our society its
history how it goes back centuries
within our society you know we were the
first country that expelled all Jews
from this country in the medieval period
and if you look at what's happened right
away across Europe the pogroms etc it is
deep within our society unless we
understand its history and its
incidences we will not be able to
eradicate it so that video it was a
short video which I thought really
well-done it just demonstrated the sort
of levels of conspiracy theories that go
around and associate with anti-semitism
that we should all learn from and
actually how you understand some of the
language that has been used as well you
know we've gone through in other
communities as well where we've learnt
those lessons and we've got to relearn
that lesson about anti-semitism as well
so why do you think that that people who
buy into some of these historic
conspiracy
there is a joining labor now well we've
expanded to over half a million member
so we're a much bigger party now so will
reflect the rest of society and what
that means is if we reflect the whole
society we will also reflect some of the
elements within society that we find
well just intolerable so in that way
you've always got to be in a situation
where we thought whatever organization
you're in especially if you're in a
magical I've been drawn to labor no I
think it's across all parts if you look
at the recent reports about the extent
of anti-semitism actually in recent
reports as actually said it's more
within the right than it is on the left
I'm not interested in arguing that point
because I want to ensure that within the
labor party as a mass movement now
anti-semitism is eradicated no matter
how small it is even if there was one
anti-semite it doesn't matter it's still
offensive we've got to we've got to
eradicate it and we will we were on that
path and we're learning well we're
learning some hard lessons about how you
do it as well but at the end of the day
as I say we learn these lessons with
eradicate anti-semitism the Labour Party
will play our role within society and
I'll be proud we've done it now just
finally I didn't want to talk to you
about the deputy leader Tom Watson and
who has decided to try and set up what
he's referring to is a social democratic
group of labour backbenchers to try and
look at different policies to broaden
the party's appeal is that party within
a party no no look we have different
groups within the labour party
we have the camper socialist campaign
which I used to chair we have the
Tribune group progress and so's Tom's
bringing other people together he has a
perfect right to do that that's fair
enough and we need as much policy debate
as we possibly can I welcome that we are
a pluralist broadchurch and let's
welcome that you know Jeremy Corbyn has
launched this whole series of seminars
and discussion groups when the Parma
Tory Labour Party because he's saying
that we've got to be prepared for the
next election we've got to be ready to
do it
and produce a new manifesto so he's
organizing a whole series of discussion
groups and bringing the Parma tree Labor
Party and also of course our party
membership so no no I I welcome that
what tom is doing I welcome the
discussions that have taken place across
all those different goes we're a broad
church and you know when it comes down
to it when it comes down to a general as
we did last time with unite around well
last time was a radical manifesto that
was incredibly successful and we'll do
that again and Tom will play his part